Cristiano Ronaldo and Georgina Rodriguez
announced the tragic news their infant
son has died Ronaldo shared the
announcement on Monday in this message
posted to his social media quote it is
with our deepest sadness we have to
announce that our baby boy has passed
away it is the greatest pain that any
parents can feel back in October the
couple revealed they were expecting
twins sharing these sonogram photos the
caption set in part our hearts are full
of love we can't wait to meet you
Ronaldo and Rodriguez share their lives
on her Netflix series I am Georgina
is
and her pregnancy was documented on
social media even this special moment
from their gender reveal party Una
those e
[Music]
h
yay
[Music]
[Laughter]
Monday's statement goes on to
acknowledge the birth of their daughter
writing quote only the birth of our baby
girl gives us the strength to live this
moment with some hope and happiness the
couple has been together since 2017.
they're also parents to Alana Ava Mateo
and Ronaldo is dead to 11 year old son
Cristiano Jr Ronaldo and Rodriguez ended
their statement with quote we would like
to thank the doctors and nurses for all
their expert care and support we are all
devastated at this loss and we kindly
ask for privacy at this very difficult
time our baby boy you are our Angel we
will always love you
foreign
[Music]